sandé of all things between the two of
you don't look like they're headed to a
good place I did change my mind and
allow him to not only come to the
wedding but to be in my wedding do I
regret that we're in the thick of season
eight how're you feeling about it
pretty good so far sorry I've just had
one freakout so far okay I'm doing
pretty good I'm liking it so far go in
on everything okay at any point you
don't want to answer one of my question
yes you have your emergency exit here
you gotta take a shot of tequila okay
right okay I think Brittany's gonna be
the shot ambassador for this group yes
our usual we're in the middle of the
bachelor bachelorette party in Miami
right I want to unpack that whole
stripper moment Jax let me explain this
for you just as well just for club last
night I felt so awkward I could not get
into it
I was the only one on all the guys who
did have a girl next three
remember we film and film and film and
film and film we were filming for about
three three and a half hours I got one
lap dance that my brother-in-law but God
and everybody
right so of course they're gonna clip to
the three-and-a-half minute lap dance
that I did say that I was having this
like great time what she said it was no
private room she didn't say no lap
dances now that was all for laughs no no
for confused cuz it's like no one was
gonna think Britney was going to be
upset denying the fact that I went into
the champagne room I think that's what
he meant but and all my other friends
that were single did go in the champagne
room not me that's why I was like no I'm
not into that plus I'm just not really
into strip clubs but all my friends paid
a lot of money to come to Miami they all
wanted me to have a good time they're
all throwing money so I'm like I gotta
have a lap dance
and that's did you see what I said I'm
dead I'm very dead inside I am very dead
inside of happily married I have a happy
wife Simon you can go ahead and do your
thing up I'll play the part but there
was one other moment though yeah I want
to split me about mhm Jax made a joke
that he might leave you for one of the
strippers that man oh I saw that again
eight o'clock no in that industry the
first shift is probably the worst shift
to have because you're the strip club
right so I got be like I got the new
crowd like the kid you know the rookie
stripper so I was being sarcastic like
yeah I'm gonna go home because they
weren't great I'm sorry so I was like
making a joke being sarcastic okay
honestly I don't make of that and well
of course I saw it on social media
before I actually got to watch the
episode for myself and I call Jax I'm
like Jax what did you do people are
sitting here saying that you're gonna
leave me for a stripper and you said
that and then I watch it myself
I watched the episode and then I was
like yeah it's like annoying that he
said that but also like I just wanted
him to have fun and I didn't take it
personally I got to be careful even
sarcasm I guess nowadays well the thing
is we are on a reality
so everything we say it comes back to
harness no back right this is must be my
bachelorette party we're supposed to
celebrate my love celebrating my
marriage Brittany we left you in the
middle of an emotional moment watching
it back do you feel like Kristin threw
some flame on the fire well now that I
wash it back I think Kristin in a way
was trying to like agree with me or
something you know to make me like feel
better but I did notice that when the
signs first came out I was like whew you
know like put pup in my fist and like
ready to party and then she said
something first
I forgot what she said like or something
and then and then I started getting
upset and then it started soaking in
like oh my gosh that's about me and I
started taking it personal
I don't blame everything on her because
I definitely felt my own feelings I took
it personal and because I was so very
drunk also it was my bachelorette party
I was allowed to be drunk but also
because of all the comments and stuff I
have to see all the time on social media
like sometimes you can't help but see
the things the hateful tweets and
comments and I think it just arched
something it just hit a nerve and it
made me like really upset next thing for
you guys the wedding is going to play
out on TV yeah wait what have you been
able to see any of the footage outside
of what's in the trailers I haven't seen
any footage yet other than yeah the
trailers and I cannot wait to see it
back I have so many photos and they're
amazing but I can't wait to see like
actual footage we get to relive it again
one you might learn some things that you
didn't know happened at you oh yeah
because people held like they were very
respectful there was a lot of drama that
was going on the loss they don't know
what I don't even know give me some
hints as to what that drama is I don't I
don't want to give away a spoiler but
like Tom and Katie go through something
and that's like that was crazy during
our wedding I had maybe learning they
were married already or not but yeah
giving a fellow Bravo family member a
lot of hard time because of this but
Shep was a handful and out of all the
people that I was really worried about
at this wedding he was supposed to be
the least I should worry about because
he's on a show and he knows how it works
so yeah he was a little bit of a handful
but you know
but I love chef just make it very clear
but yeah he was a handful
well yeah cause he posted me like
walking down the aisle and all that okay
so he likes spoiled everything
he did it was just the least the last
person I would expect to do that because
they're honest shows that's really the
worst thing he did he was mad it wasn't
like he wanted ate the cake yeah did
anything like that go down like somebody
no shorts was probably he was wasted
absolutely wasted him his best man
speech I went on a little was in the
past I don't like to give Tom Schwartz
too much responsibility because he gets
anxiety but I put it all on and then he
knocked it out of the park yeah hey
growth yeah the other Tom yeah sand of
all things between the two of you don't
look like they're headed to a good place
a problem with I did change my mind and
allow him to not only come to the
wedding but to be in my wedding
do I regret that yes I just wish I would
have stood by what I said I felt I was a
little bit bullied into bringing him
back in and I didn't for me because I
thought that he needed I just think what
he did here there's some things he did
during the season that haven't played
out yet that were just uncalled for
absolutely uncalled for below the belt
should never ever happen to a friend and
I made my decision that I did not want
on I just wish she wasn't in the wedding
but that it's any sense you know the
things that I was going through with Tom
it just it was it didn't make sense for
him to be standing there but I have a
feeling in five years if Tom stainable
was not in our wedding photos that would
be very weird for Jax like they're gonna
be friends again I know any of our
friends it's not that they're not
friends but we're just cordial when
you're friends with semi for that long
like it means something there they're
like part of your family so that was why
it was so important for me to make sure
he had that but it's also okay for
people to grow apart there's nothing
wrong with him he he's stubborn I'm
stubborn I don't agree with what he does
he doesn't agree with
I do and that's part of life I want
different things he wants different
things I'm trying to get married and
start a family he doesn't want to do
that and I'm just into like different
things and it's okay it's alright I just
you know we butt heads it's part of life
well there's a some scenes that have
been teased coming up you scream and
sand them all at one point yes I walk
around on eggshells and shanks does
whatever that's why are you trying to
see why you'll see it and I don't want
to give it away but it's how bad is it
that you get pushed to that point well
because you would always expect your
best friends to be on your side and have
your back and not question your judgment
or your character and I felt like that's
what Tom did and that really upset me
because he knows us very well and he
knows the type of people that we are and
just to even like second-guessed
especially in front of my friends in
public it just was it just was very
disrespectful and it really hurt my
feelings
okay especially after how hard I worked
to try to like I mean not only did he do
it with Stassi but then he did it with
me so he obviously didn't learn his
lesson alright yeah Shawn I think people
know I'm gonna tell you how it is I'm
not gonna sugarcoat anything I think
people need to know the truth well
you've been you've had a lot to say
about Tom's girlfriend
Ariana really what is that the core of
your issue with her but I have been
around her for the last 15 years so I
know the type of person she is and I've
seen over the years how negative she can
be and it's you know we are I'm so
grateful to be part of the show I
everyday I think God and my lucky stars
and you know her constant putting down
things and putting down the show and
just I just I don't don't stand for it
and her better than I'm it I'm better
than everybody else attitude and if it
doesn't coincide with her then it's
terrible it's not fun if it's not up to
her then it's just and I've had enough I
know I probably sorry okay I don't I
don't
hater I just don't agree it makes it
hard on our friendship
you're like posting bad things about her
online you don't even hang out with Aria
I'm good here as much by the way
but someone did oh my god I was glad she
was there say we are so off this
actually what it works yeah we're both
stubborn it wouldn't work no I'd be
arrested I just want to love everybody
and just welcome everybody knows I'm a
realist I'll tell you how it is and how
life doesn't always work that way
but I love how she is I wouldn't have it
any other way thank you
well Arianna was sitting there not too
long ago master of anyone in the group
you'd be okay never speaking to again
she said you yeah as long as it meant
she could still see you yeah I feel the
same I just don't want people to feel
awkward around each other that's the
hard part about our group of friends is
we are always together and if somebody
is fighting like that it makes the
entire group feel awkward well let's
talk about a different instance of that
in this group where do you guys fall in
the hole Katie and Stassi versus Kristen
think you're being an obnoxious person
right now maybe you're just a [ __ ] to
me all the time she'll be real for one
second Kristen we both kind of caught in
the middle first of all I definitely see
both sides and I'd completely understand
why Katie and Stassi like needed to take
a break because they were literally
fighting every time they were together
every single time so it's good that they
are taking this time apart I just hope
that they can find each other again you
know like that would be great because
then we could all hang out together
again I know how to do this when this
person that's that day this is that
person I don't think it's gonna happen
anytime soon
me and Stassi hate that Kristen thinks
that they were never good friends
because like I think offended them the
most so it's it's so hard because I get
I get yeah both sides I really do
because she at least cut off the Carter
at all okay yep
Betty progress so anyhow so she's single
she's dating around yeah no go harder so
Kristen is amazing
so I can't wait for her to shoes
yeah she's a great a great person she's
been a great friend to me I she's the
one person I would trust with my own kid
yeah so he's great that's a big
endorsement yeah really our dating life
that means work do you think those three
can repair things before stassi's
wedding because the clock is kind of on
yeah it is on I hope so I mean they are
talking a little bit so that is good
news my fingers are crossed I don't
think this is also the yin yang thing
like multiple wagers going on behind the
scenes oh there's like over-unders
there's uh yeah there's a lot of a lot
of wagers going on and if it's gonna
happen I personally think it's not gonna
happen
i stassi's a very stubborn person and
she wants the wedding her way she does
not care who she hurts yeah he doesn't
care it's pretty nice we meet somebody
like we met somebody five minutes ago
they would be invited or stassi's got
you know friends of hers from a long
time that aren't coming but she wants
her wedding is certainly well there's
two big weddings coming up now Stassi
and Beau and Lala and Randall and you
guys have said you're putting starting a
family on pause until those two big
events
well not putting it all the way on pause
look at like maybe within the next
couple months we're gonna because you
can't travel after seven months
absolutely it's in Italy so I always use
this reference Phoebe from fringe get
stuck behind and can't go to England
with Ross when he's marrying Emily so
I'm like I don't want to be Phoebe I
can't fly I'm having my brother's babies
I don't want to miss like my best
friend's biggest moments ago they were
there for me and it's important for me
to be there for them but that is the
last thing that we that's the last time
we will ever delay the process and that
also doesn't mean I don't care to be
pregnant that does not mine at all to be
pregnant whenever you know yeah that
would be July
so there's Neela bottle comes off what
were maybe Stassi and Lala's reactions
to hearing that you were taking that
into consideration so we all talked
about it all four of us me Katie Stassi
and Lola we but we always say that we
have a pregnancy pact we want to have
babies around the same time so I mean
we're all just trying to make it work
it's it's a big deal and for us to all
have our kids around the same time and
to grow up together that's a big deal
all right 20 21 maybe a baby boom in the
valley yeah how many kids do you guys
want have you three I think it's like
how's the first kid events I'm very
excited to see you two as parents I
couldn't be more excited to be a dad
like I I can't wait to be the father
like my father was and just to give give
and just to be there for everything and
to just make sure my life is surround it
it revolves around my kids and that's
exactly what I'm gonna do
Oh shifting gears I have some rapid fire
questions that where these shots might
come or if it's wrong I take this one
right here you don't want to answer it
so like I said with Ariana she said she
would be up on never talking gonna so
who would you be okay never talking to
again from your cast Ariana I don't know
I feel like I would talk today everybody
right I don't know I can't say there's
anybody ever talk to him again okay I'm
good friends with Ariana's brother
Jeremy and I don't know how they came
from the same cloth I really don't
I'm getting this Grayson you're doubling
down could it be more obvious I'm sure
he's gonna love hearing all this that
you're talking about sister no he knows
all right who is someone on your cast
you feel like you owe an apology to
nobody
I'm sure right now like as of right now
or just overall in the in the whole span
of the time we've been left my wife
obviously I think for obvious reasons
other than that I would never apologize
to me but if I had to apologize guys I
would I think I'm at the point in my
life now where I I can apologize and I
always have I'm the first one to if I'm
wrong I will apologize and say I'm sorry
but if I know I'm right I will not
apologize I mean I get embarrassed when
I ride like yell because that's not my
personality nobody really sees that so
like whenever I yield at James in the
reunion last year I got a person like
you are that's still not me to react
like that
so I apologized to him for even you know
doing that he apologized to me so we're
cool now and I even I think apologized
to st. of all because I was telling Jack
to beat him up that night so which I
don't really know about you watch that
episode there's absolutely no reason you
should apologize your wedding is
bringing something that we love in the
Bravo verse of like Bravo Liberty
crossover mhf is gonna be there are
there any Vanderpump rules and Bravo lab
hookups we don't know about and Kristen
talked about it on up with pretty much
everybody for The Bachelor open to
I think I don't know if she Nehring Shep
over like who's that bro yeah I'm good
mate oh yeah I think just I think Sheena
and Carl from summerhouse their
publicist is a rat like holding her it's
juicy you're right there's okay all
right last one what is the wildest place
the two of you have ever hooked up oh my
god boy we are in the know and we got to
go to the Bahamas with la langue Randall
and they had this like huge yacht that
we stayed in for the whole week
I never thought that would be on a yacht
like that some have to say the yacht
yeah okay because I never imagined I
would be it yeah yeah hey you survived
only one shot that's alright to wrap
things up here
what's the beer cheese update pray that
everything works out we are working with
a company that is in Kentucky in
Lexington actually so very local oh you
have to go through the legal steps but
within the next month a month and a half
you should be able to order it all over
the US and in Canada how much of the
profits is your grandma getting and
we're figuring all that out but no
matter what ma'am all will be taken care
of she's the star thank you guys yeah ox
was spilled hopefully not too much thank
just enough
[Music]